hey 42 here you probably associate fairy
tales with a sweeter more innocent time
in your life
perhaps your mum or dad used to read
them to you whilst you were tucked up
underneath your duvet in paisley pajamas
dreaming a faraway land where
stepmothers were bad news little girls
wore red riding hoods and magic beans
were a sound financial investment
a place where bad people got what was
coming to them and good people lived
happily ever after
but what five-year-old you probably
didn't know was the stories you were
being fed were heavily sanitized
versions of the originals and i don't
mean cleaned up a bit with some spit and
polish
more like scrubbed down with a wire
brush and bleach
in their unedited now largely forgotten
forms most fairy tales were in reality
stories of murder cannibalism rape
dismemberment and incest seasoned with a
sprinkling of child abuse racism and
gratuitous violence imagine snow white
and the seven dwarves directed by
quentin tarantino after a bad breakup
and you'll have a sense of what i mean
not exactly bedtime fodder for little
munchkins
these fairy stories
would have made your average fairy
themselves although the term fairy tale
was coined in the late 17th century
these stories have reached that go back
a very long way in both spoken and
written history with some thought to be
up to 6 000 years old
fairy tales are embedded deeply within
cultures they're essentially a set of
master narratives intended to influence
people's beliefs and values as well as
shape their behavior they regularly
contain a culture spiritual and moral
codes and often build on real events
they're also repeated in cultures across
the world
the story of cinderella for instance
isn't only found in europe a version of
the same tale is also found in the west
indies where it isn't a pumpkin that
transforms into a carriage but
breadfruit
in ancient china the story probably
dates back to the 9th century and tells
how a servant girl loses a slipper made
of gold the oldest known version of the
cinderella folk tale about a slave girl
called rodolfis was popular in ancient
greece
rodolphus's leather sandal is stolen by
an eagle while she's bathing
i hate it when that happens when the
eagle drops the sandal in the lap of the
king he's so overcome by its beautiful
shape that he sends men all over the
kingdom to find its own
eventually road office is found and made
queen
forever satisfying the king's obvious
foot fetish in the egyptian version of
the story cinderella wears practical
sounding red leather slippers not the
high maintenance glass kind
that detail was added in the 17th
century by french writer charles
perrault who compiled many of the
stories that would become well-known
fairy tales including sleeping beauty i
give you all this detail not because i
have a thing for women's shoes honestly
i don't but to highlight how the fairy
tales you know so well actually have
dramatically different narratives
depending on who's telling them
in some versions of cinderella the
heroine isn't helped by a fairy
godmother but by her own dead mother who
reappears as some form of domestic
animal or lives incarnated in a hazel
tree
likewise cinderella doesn't always go to
a ball sometimes it's a festival or
church
and in some versions there's no swapping
of slippers at all cinderella's identity
is proved by a ring that fits only her
finger the details vary so much because
what we think of as fairy tales were
originally just folk stories
mostly handed down through an oral
tradition of storytelling and as
cultures mixed across the centuries
through human migration and trading
the stories mixed with them as you
probably know the famed brothers grim
provided the source material for most of
the fairy tales we tell today at least
in the western world what the stories
they recorded in grimm's fairy tales
were by no means original
in fact the collection was an attempt to
preserve these ancient tales for future
generations
it's safe to say that went pretty well
the grimms interviewed relatives friends
and pretty much anyone else they could
find to hunt down traditional folk
stories
their most prolific contributor was
dorothy pearson wieman who had heard
many tales from travellers as a popular
inn owned by her father like a lot of
things you hear down the local boozer
these stories weren't exactly suitable
for children's ears but the grimms
didn't let that worry them too much
despite the fact their book was targeted
at kids it was packed full of x-rated
content
rapunzel let down her hair each night so
that the dashing prince could climb the
tower for some netflix and chill the
long-haired princess was eventually
banished from the kingdom after getting
pregnant with the prince's illegitimate
child and in the frog prince
let's just say the princess was only
just getting started when she kissed a
frog
although thankfully she did wait until
the amphibian had transformed into a
human being before advancing past first
base after receiving some frankly
understandable criticism for filling a
children's book with boats and hoes the
grimms did tone down some of the sexual
themes in later editions of the fairy
tales but perhaps to get their own back
on the spoilsport trying to censor them
the brothers upped the gratuitous
violence to make up for it in one
version of cinderella the stepsisters
cut off parts of their own feet in order
to try and wedge their shoes into
cinder's lost slipper
when their deception is found out a
couple of doves fly down and peck the
sisters eyes out in a lesser-known fairy
tale called the robber bridegroom
criminals kidnap a young woman and force
her to drink wine until her heart
explodes before stripping her naked and
chopping her body into pieces in the
goose maid a woman is tucked into a
barrel filled with spikes and pulled
through the streets
and in snow white the wicked queen is
forced to dance in red-hot iron's shoes
until she collapses and dies
in another story called the juniper tree
the stepmother yes another one is so
consumed with hatred she decapitates her
stepson
she then balances his head on top of his
body and uses a scarf to hide the cut
when her daughter enters the room and
asks why her stepbrother looks so pale
the stepmother suggests a girl give the
boy a slap to revive him naturally the
boy's head falls off and the wicked
stepmother convinces the little girl
she's murdered her sibling to hide the
evidence they chop up the boy's body and
turn it into a stream which is then
served to his father
yeah it's brutal stuff but not at all
unusual in grimm's fairy tales where
plenty of violence is aimed at children
in frau trude a girl who doesn't listen
to her parents gets turned into a block
of wood and thrown into the fire by a
witch
in snow white the little girl is only
seven years old when the huntsman is
told to take her to the forest kill her
and bring back her liver and lungs for
the queen to consume child cannibalism
is another theme that runs through these
tales in the juniper tree dad
unwittingly eats sun
and if you remember the story of hansel
and gretel you'll recall that two
children who run away after hearing
their soon to be abandoned almost get
eaten by a witch except in the original
version of the story it's not the awful
stepmother who decides the children must
be left to fend for themselves
it's the children's own mother and
father that detail offers a clue as to
why children are so badly treated in
these stories
you see life for young people in the
1800s was mostly pretty awful the
industrial revolution saw families
living in poverty and squalored
conditions
as a result children were regularly
abandoned sold or forced to work as
expendable labor the story of snow white
for example is possibly based on the
real life story of margarite von waldek
a 16th century bavarian noblewoman
marguerite's brother put small children
to work in his copper mine the physical
labor deforming them so much they became
known as dwarves
as well as reflecting the time in which
they were written there's another reason
these stories were so graphic to scare
the living crap out of children scaring
youngsters into good behavior is still
pretty common these days but 150 years
ago it was standard practice striking
fear into the hearts of children was
often linked to religion and avoiding
hell which isn't really all that
different to how many religions sell
their words
even today it's hard to believe that
grimm's fairy tales could have been any
darker but they also had a healthy dose
of anti-semitism thrown in for good
measure which is probably why the nazis
adopted grimm's tales for propaganda
purposes and made them compulsory
reading in every german school after a
little adaptation of course
little red riding hood became symbolic
of the german people tormented by the
jewish wolf
and cinderella was apparently aryan
which was what distinguished her from
her stepsisters and made them so jealous
after the second world war these books
and stories were banned in some places
but even when stripped of sex violence
and nazi symbolism
fairy tales still come under fire
as you probably know even squeaky clean
disney have had their share of heat for
reinforcing negative racial and gender
stereotypes over the years
it's strange to think that the fairy
tales enjoyed by millions of children
around the world were once horror
stories full of murder cannibalism and
torture
but folk tales have always acted as a
kind of magic mirror on the wall
reflecting humanity's own fears
struggles and prejudices
right back at us
and let's face it it's been clear for
some time that we humans aren't always
the fairest of them all thanks for
watching